it was always going to be your kitty
in game two for those that wondered is
this a lance mccullar start
yeah and again jose katie he's been
great and he's been great against
left-handed hitting
specifically and that's because of his
change-up he'll throw it at any count
and he's kept those left-handed hitters
at bay with it
and now an opportunity for the big fella
miguel cino with two on
3-1 slider away ball four or kitty
looks in wondering where was that and
now they're loaded
by manny alex kiriloff called up and
added to the roster
the third player to debut in the
postseason and the first to ever start
he's not just starting he's starting in
an elimination
game in his first major they get back
he's got the bags loaded in the first
inning o2 hit it to center field
and it well but springer is there and
welcome to the major leagues
alex kirilla what a story leaves them
loaded
zeroes after one and now you have jose
berrios on the mound
what gives you confidence is this is the
guy that was
built and groomed in this organization
for this moment yeah we approach every
game uh
the same way our guys prepare and are
able to focus and are able to uh
wipe clean anything that happens the day
before whether it's good or
or uh not so much that's a heck of a
play right there
sure is barrios bounces off the mound as
tucker trying to bunt into the shift
heck of a play and guys guys that right
there was an eye papa moment
from jose verrillos an easy one two
three inning in the top of the second
due to that defense by jose berniers
on the day where roberto clemente hits 3
000 hit 48 years later he makes that
play
2-2 big pitch kyle tucker 4th inning 0-0
two men on
and he got jammed but this one is a
seeing-eye single it's gonna get through
and the astros see brantley come around
to score
and they lead it one to nothing as kyle
tucker delivers the first run of the
game
a really good location on the fastball
inside exactly what he wanted to do
you're looking at a pitch right there
where exit velocity was just
82.2 miles per hour off the bat you see
the shift
just he hit him where they're not this
brings up alex kirilov
1-1 that's ripped into right field
that's exactly what
rocco baldelli told us about alex
kirilov he is a
absolute huge elite bat power to all
fields and he can play both corner
outfields in first base
congratulations to alex kiriloff on his
first major league hit coming
in the postseason and as a result we
will ask for the baseball
he's played in 62 career postseason
games
this one he hit to right center field
kiriloff is going over
sliding catch alex kirilov
max kepler gave way to the rookie right
fielder and he comes up with the web gem
letting rocco valdelli and the minnesota
twins know
one of the biggest reasons besides his
bat why he's in there
calls it off never takes his eye off it
completely stretched out beautifully
done keeping correct
first base and getting you out are you
kidding first game in a year plus
that's a great catch this is a moment
that rayleigh does not have to give in
at all to nelson cruz
there's a base open this is not a good
matchup for rayleigh
and he boomsticked one into left and
that one is over the head
of kyle tucker and it goes over his head
just like reddick yesterday
marwyn gonzalez is in throw home
out at home it did not look like a rise
touched home and he's tagged out
for the third out but nelson cruz
delivers soft raleigh to tie this game
up at one
in the bottom of the fifth inning
right there rosario's helmet flies off
on a 94 mile an hour
puerto rico letting him know exactly
come on really
got a great little smile here 3-1
called strike two rosario he's barking
now
manny gonzalez great two into the mid of
maldonado and rosario has a word and he
gets thrown out
mandy gonzalez tossed him right after
that
ball into the mitt you could see rosario
look back and talk to manny gonzalez
and he threw him out now rocco baldelli
is out there yelling
but rosario said i never looked or said
anything at you and you're throwing me
out of the game andy rosario
removed that leaves jake cave who you
just saw he's the only other outfielder
listed on the roster and he is now in
left field
offenses have been really quiet doesn't
feel like the ball
is carrying at all and dusty had told us
that at least by observation the winds
were blowing out to right and left but
have you seen a ball hit that you
thought wow that
that one has a chance to go correa hits
this one far
kepler looks up and just as we talked
about no power
alex correa hits a home run
105 9 off the bat and the astros
on top 2-1 the second hit of the game
and a big one for the houston astros
gets his arms extended
drives it that way big home run for the
first round draft pick
here comes the 3-2 nope he walked nelson
cruz
and now the go-ahead run will come to
the plate
as byron buxton emerges from the dugout
dangerous hitter here miguel cino
now they get him in a rundown buxton is
caught off the bag
and he's tagged out and what a disaster
for the twins
yeah and he was going first move no
matter what and
he guessed wrong instead of trusting
what he sees
and then going and trusting the process
martine maldonado's
arm has a lot to do with it also
nobody out first and third ninth inning
of a 2-1 game
on the ground and through and kyle
tucker's delivered again as brantley
comes in to score
and the astros pad their lead now up
three to
one one out away the astros from moving
on
that strike three from presley and the
astros win it three to one
and they sweep the wild card series two
games to none
holding the twins offense completely
in check watch out here comes houston